speaking of Quentin Tarantino possibly
uh you know his his method uh that he
likes to take revenge on people on the
set who are who fall asleep he had a a
weapon of choice there was a large dildo
he's something like this something like
that I don't know who this is made
snores would be found in various corners
of the set would be brought out like
like jaws and then we'd be sort of
presented in some really ungodly
horrific sort of angle next to the face
of the offending sleeper they would be
photographs to be taken as the
photographs were taken there was a wall
like a wall of shame that started to be
built I attempted to kidnap this wall on
several occasions I I do remember that
at one point during a scene we heard
snoring and found it was Bill our first
A.D right I think he got hit up with the
a Big Ben I think they called it they
called it Big Ben